mais là on va se diriger sur le poste de
préparation tissu qui va être votre
poste c'est comme si elle faisait déjà
partie de la maison on retrouve le tissu
la barousse ont des découpes même si
elle en a tout l'air stéphanie n'est pas
encore tout à fait embaucher dans
l'entreprise pour l'instant elle ne fait
que candidature à un poste et ne s'agit
donc pour elle que d'une visite de
repérage
ça permet de voir où est ce que je vais
mettre les pieds mais mes débuts donc
c'est essentiel est essentiel avant
d'aborder l'entretien d'embûches en
bonne et due forme
allez je me laisse tourner sur la gauche
si la visite s'est bien passé pour
stéphanie elle préfère au moins pour le
moment
optez pour l'intérim en intérim pour
pour être libre quand même après avoir
réfléchi s'il ya une embauche au bout il
ya vraiment aucun souci car c'est bien
la finalité pour l'entreprise qui a
besoin de nouvelles têtes
elle exporte ses véhicules ibori fidh
dans près de 40 pays sur son site tout
récent de saint-eusèbe elle compte 100
salariés
mais ce n'est toujours pas assez alors
la boîte est prête à donner du sien pour
former ses futurs employés à partir d'un
savoir être on est capable de transférer
un savoir faire
donc on est une véritable école de
formation chez lanvin c'est comme ça
qu'à 22 ans
yoann a accepté de laisser tomber
l'intérim en moins d'un an dans
l'entreprise n'a pu enfiler le casque de
chef d'équipé
j'arrive et je connaissais bah rien je
fais partie de rien puis du coup
attendant les pièges des deux dans ma
tête je les connais par coeur les
injections c'est pareil c'est vrai si
une bonne progression donc un moyen de
progresser dans les prochaines semaines
l'entreprise de sainte sève compte
embaucher une trentaine de salariés